all right it is time for drew's news
where we get to hang out the news net
and gently snag those beautiful good
news butterflies
nothing but net
and with me at the desk is a man as
graceful as a butterfly rossi ross
matthews
hi everybody hi
hi
oh it's douglas douglas is right down
here hi
i mean remember when it was you me and
douglas i do remember i am so happy he's
come for visiting day all right first up
this story is uh it's a mind twister but
it's got a lot of depth um cole sprouse
um who is the handsome talented
beautiful wonderful actor
um that we've watched grow up in fact
him and his twin brother
um were in big daddy and they became
huge disney stars with their show the
suite life of zach and cody and now e
news reports that coal is coming to the
defense of young actresses who grew up
as child stars themselves saying that
men get applauded for coming out
unscathed from those careers but young
women
are you know tend to be heavily
sexualized from an earlier age and
there's really absolutely no way that he
thinks he and his brother could have
survived if they had comparable
experiences and cole says that he will
definitely always defend actresses who
had to make it through the gauntlet of
child stardom they're here to keep
people aware of how we kind of conduct
ourselves in this business and to be
aware moving forward very beautifully
said yeah on a fascinating conversation
specifically with you who grew up in the
industry i mean you must relate to this
i don't think i was uh
i didn't grow up uh
sexy you know that was and that ended up
being an empowered choice on my own when
i was in my late teens but it is hard
growing up at all let alone in front of
everybody and when you have
a job that is required to take all of
your boundaries out of the picture
that is confusing at any age so i always
love when i see men
um defending women i love when i see
boys defending girls i like that they're
asking the industry to please allow
girls to grow up without capitalizing on
their looks these are healthy
conversations and in a world of a lot of
toxic masculinity you have something
like this that is a complete
counterbalance to it so i appreciated
them coming out and
speaking out on behalf of their fellow
female co-workers i do too i think it's
great i don't know how you did it
all right well next up can you believe
it you guys it's almost graduation
season right
hey prom hey graduation oh my god ross
you and i would have been the perfect
prom date what do you mean would have
been how about could have been we should
what about can't we be why can't we
throw a prom here if it's good enough
for carrie and stanford we can do it
let's do a prom we should do a prom here
would you guys show up
yes
all right
well another thing it's not just prom
season it's graduation yeah we can go
all the way that night ross yeah we can
no no you're gonna be disappointed at
the end of the prom i'll tell you that
you're not you're like
i'm not for you there is not enough
spike in the punch for that to happen
drew at prom
um well right here in new york city it
is graduation time and nyu has got an
epic keynote speaker listen to this oh
yeah taylor swift everybody is doing it
that's
crazy that is crazy when insider reports
there's a huge market for graduation
tickets to this so swifties are flooding
the internet offering to pay students up
to 500 a pop to get into the ceremony so
this is what listen college students
have been going to school for four years
it's graduation time and they're selling
their tickets because taylor swift is
going to be there and i get it let me
tell you something i feel like i have a
phd in taylor swift lyrics you know
absolutely but i think about my
graduation and i think it was like our
keynote speaker was carl from hr you
know what i mean like and these kids at
nyu get taylor swift it seems like too
good to be true i i did a little
research it's not the ceremony where you
do like the cap and gown and get the
diploma oh what is it so you still could
do that and i say if you need a little
cash
sell
do it yeah i mean why not yeah i i it's
a yankee stadium too which is so special
but is she gonna sing or she just gonna
read a speech i would figure that she
would be giving a speech okay but i'd
wanted to sing i'd be like say i know
i'd be that guy in the back you know i
was thinking
you would be a great commencement
speaker have you ever done that
no
but i didn't attend school do you have
to have attended school to give a
commencement speech no i just think you
have to have carved an interesting and
unique path in the world that qualifies
you to be able to speak on such things
hello am i right
you'll be fabulous
i'll join with you that was a highlight
of my life to hear you say that i would
be honored
[Music]
you